Hello everyone.
I'm Abid Matini.
I'm senior backend developer at OGOV.
Thanks to AI Engineer World Fair 2026
for giving me a time slot for online
track.
And I'm going to walk you through
bypassing the multimodal text today.
How we can have a have a framework free
hybrid rag.
Withdraw SQL RF and live telemetry. As
you can see, I have got my live demo in
the right side of the screen. So,
[snorts]
any slide that I pass and if there is
anything related
related to my
presentation, I can show you. I have few
tabs also ready here for you to show and
walk you through
uh
the slides and the demos.
Okay, let's begin.
So,
we have two problems for every document
we have two problems that
we try to solve today.
One is when we start to chat with any
LLM and if we have to upload a document,
we usually going to just drag and drop a
PDF or a Word doc or an image and ask
the chatbot to get ready for the
questions that going to come up
after we upload those documents. The
issue with that is
as soon as we upload these documents, we
going to
basically
lose some of our tokens that we supposed
to have only for
uh
processing these documents without even
asking a question. So, we already uh
spend some tokens there without even
asking any questions.
That would be the first issue. And then,
if we're building a chatbot and it's uh
we want to
have vector database there, we want to
have keyword search and semantic search
there, and we want to just add more
tools. This is going to be too many
tools uh
uh combined all together. So, in the
production uh in the production
basically chatbot, we're going to have
uh
too many tools, and it's going to be
complicated for us to manage
uh
our production chatbot properly.
So, today I'm going to uh
walk you through in uh three main
uh sections. One is
how we can uh
upload our documents and get our
documents and make it ready
bef- uh for our chatbot before uh users
going to chat. So, on the on the right
side, I have I do have
a
FAQ assistant chatbot
that's running locally now for me.
And
um
I'm going to show you the dashboard, the
dashboard that I've created for it, and
how we can chat, and uh how we get the
results. So, this is going to be a
uh supposedly FAQ um
assistant for a sample employee
handbook. So, imagine that you have HR
company, and this HR has uploaded the
the the the handbook for uh
for uh for the employees to ask their
question, any question they have about
leave, about uh
uh
like uh
different kinds of leaves, and sickness,
or uh parent like uh parental leave, or
any other questions related to
our, uh uh,
possibly an HR would have as a common
question that they get every day.
So,
um, that would be one sample that we're
going to use to upload.
So, all documents can get can get in the
different formats or we can upload in
different formats of PDF, uh,
like PowerPoint documents and Word
documents or even image.
So, we're going to talk about that.
We're going to talk about how we have to
chunk these because we're talking about
drag here. We need to know how we can
chunk this information
uh, properly based on our the documents.
So, we're going to talk about
uh, different type of chunking here as
well.
We can, uh, we show you in the admin how
we can choose different
uh,
different strategies to uh, to chunk the
documents. Then we're going to see how
the search is going to work, how the
embedding is going to work, how did our
database is going to be, how the search
going to be based on the keyword search
or the semantic search.
And we're going to see about the how our
F in the Python going to work. And then
we're going to talk about the
observability, how we going to check the
safety, how we going to observe, uh, all
the process with LangFuse and how, uh,
we can the prevent, uh,
prompt injection pattern or, um,
any risky question that might come to
LLM. I'm planning this talk for about
under an hour and this,
uh, the whole thing, the plan is the
entire code base can be easily will be
running on the GitHub code code space
which you can just pull from the repo
and one command run and it's going to be
ready to test
on GitHub code spaces.
Um so, the stack we're using here are
Python, FastAPI
for the back end, React for the front
end, uh PostgreSQL for our database.
Uh Docker for just easily being able to
have the containers and we can just re-
re- produce it anywhere and rerun it
anywhere, for example, in code spaces or
code spaces or any other uh environment
we want.
Then, we have Ollama and local language
models and local language models and
embedding models that running only
locally that can be run on any uh server
as well. It doesn't need a GPU. The CPU
is going to be good enough for it. So,
uh any staging server, any code space uh
uh going going to be fine for it.
And LangFuse for uh tracking what's
going on and how we can see the chat and
the latency
uh
so, we can improve our chats
better.
Um
This is the end-to-end blueprint of uh
what we're going to talk about. So,
we're going to have a document few
documents as a source of truth for our
chatbot. So, we're going to upload some
documents.
So, what we can do with Python is we're
using Doc Link
to convert those uh
raw documents uh to markdown files.
And then, we're going to chunk those
markdown files to uh in our into our uh
PostgreSQL.
And then, we can also do some um scan as
well here. So, uh that would happen as
well. Then, we would have some queries
from the user. So, the employee is
asking questions, HR-related questions,
and it's going to be retrieved from the
database. Is the the the result relevant
results with the top rank would be
passed through the LLM.
And LLM would uh return the in the in
our chatbots that we have here.
Uh in the format of chat, so we can see
and get our questions answered here, and
we can observe in the length views
what's going on in our system.
So,
um
optimizing data ingest. So, we have two
different ways of optimizing. So, if we
first uh going to just
throw it into the We have a document,
and if we just uploading it on our
um
uh cloud chatbot anywhere,
the issue we just uh having of the one
issue we have is we're spending tokens
before we doing anything. Another issue
is you don't know how that document
looks li- looks like there and that
chunking
uh how it's being chunked and how uh
basically that LLM is seeing it. So,
that would be a risk quality. If if
there is a table that we don't know how
it's being read there, so we kind of
don't see. We're trying to uh have more
clarity about how the
how the document's being stored in our
database and how it's being retrieved.
So, another way would be a structure
first, so we use the local CPU.
If you're running it here, we we can uh
upload a document or doc link would
convert it to uh markdown file, and we
would know the better chunk uh how the
chunking is going to work. I'm going to
show you a few examples.
And uh of course, it's going to be a
cheaper prompt. If after that you want
to talk to a lo- um
an online cloud any- but if you want to
If you want to have it locally, then it
would be actually no cost
for you.
Uh, so the DocLink pipeline would be
uh,
we would be running it
It's like a local locally running it on
our server. The The The Python is going
to get that document. It's going to
export it to the markdown and save that
markdown file. Then the get this going
to chunk it based on different strategy
and uh, we're using embedding models to
embed it to our database and
insert that on to our
vector database.
Uh, so if we
save while local because
uh, imagine if if one or two pages the
cost is next to nothing, but if you have
200 pages
uh, then the cost going to be too much.
And if you have
a big
company with lots of employees and they
want to just us keep asking the same
questions
or uh,
if they want to upload documents then
it's going to be uh,
going to be a big cost.
So, um,
there are four ways of chunking a
document. Let me first before I show you
the four ways, let me uh,
show you the admin page that what I'm
talking about. So, imagine here you have
We are We're having our FAQ admin page.
So,
uh,
imagine you have
Let me delete few of the documents that
I have chunked before here. So,
uh, you want to upload a new FAQ
uh, file
for your HR
as for for your HR policy. I want to
show uh,
give your chatbot
uh, data updated with our AI system. So,
imagine you have
um
you have some question answers here. Uh
before I do that, let me show you here
what I mean. So, [snorts]
um
this is the heading FAQ, yeah. So,
one way that you can feed our chatbot
with information is if we actually
create a question answer
uh file. So, that would be easier to
digest for our uh
system to understand what's going on.
So, part of that is uh imagine we're
having a this the entire FAQ file.
So, the entire uh
basically handbook. If we want to chunk
this uh handbook and just upload it,
imagine uh we're uploading the entire
PDF. This is going to be the way our PDF
is going to look like after chunking.
So,
it started by acknowledgement, then they
see a few chunk that doesn't have any
meaning.
And then something starts here. There
are some chunks that doesn't have any
meaning.
Uh for example, here signature date,
that's basically kind of useless. So,
this going to slow down and reduce the
accuracy of
our chat. It's going to increase
hallucination. So, um
instead of
uploading uh straight uh 28 pages,
we can if we can divide our documents to
different chunks and just to different
files, relevant files, and clean up that
data a bit as much as we can, uh and
then upload it, then we will have a
better result. So, uh
one way of
uh
uploading in the FAQ case is to actually
have your your turning your data to
question and answers. So,
uh
So, talking about working hours, talking
about different situations here, so you
can have it based on questions and
answers. Then this way you know when you
reference your documents, you're having
the
uh
correct reference, and it won't be any
confusing.
And there are
uh different way to uh upload your
documents. One way is you have the
question and answer, and then you would
like to upload it. This is my FAQ PDF
file.
Uh same PDF file, and I'd like to upload
it based on
uh
heading-based chunking strategy.
That means well, while I'm explaining
the the
parsing where Docling is happening in
the background. So, that means each
uh
chunking would be based on the heading
that Docling would find.
And the answer that comes based on that.
So, each heading and answer is going to
heading as a question and answer is
going to become a chunk. So, we know our
chunking is clean,
and it's easy to uh reference.
So, when this chunking finishes in a
seconds, we would see, okay, this is the
first FAQ, it could chunk successfully
to uh
based on the headings. So, it recognized
the heading question,
uh
and then the relevant answer. So, each
chunk has its own
uh question and answer here. So, if we
say
uh
if we say, for example, uh
>> Um
as our questions here
Uh
do we
do we have
or something like this. So, we should
expect a kind of answer with the
reference that's coming to that chunk.
So, we talking about heading chance
going to understand the documents based
on
uh headings that you have. That's how
it's going to chunk each document
heading by heading. So, as you can see
here, um
our question was about how much This was
the question we prepared, and this was
the answer we prepared. Uh sample
Coca-Cola 90% of the individual
employee premium and 75%
dependent premium. What we see here as a
reference, we getting that answer, and
not only that, you getting the correct
answer, you also getting the
Uh you see that it's been this answer
has been generated based on this
document, based on this chunk. So, it's
easy to reference. It's easy, you know,
where the issue is if there is anything
that's not working, you know why. Then
you can go track it why this right chunk
hasn't been retrieved. So, in this way
you
have more
uh more uh clear path towards how you
can debug it. Because I was uh in our
system, I was asking for um
return top two chunks, it would uh
suggesting me I'll talk about all these
models here. Um it would bring top two
response. So, then it was also checking
that sample employee handbook that big
file here, sample employee handbook.
As you can see here, that's a big chunk.
And if actually it's a good example
because if you compare these two, uh
because we just drag uh
uploaded the entire chunk here, you can
see although it's returned some
information, but it's not that accurate
and you don't know. Of course, it went
through that file and found something,
but
uh
you don't know how accurate that
information could be and you can't
follow because the chunk is is just uh
uh
untrackable that easily. So,
one way of chunking is chunking based on
the headings.
Second way of chunking is based on the
paragraph. So, technically when you
upload your documents, you would say
uh
just chunk each paragraph you catch,
have it as a separate chunk. Doesn't
matter there is a heading or not heading
or anything. So, uh
if I want to go back to the
to our
to our documents and say, let me first
choose I want to do a paragraph
chunking. I want to say, okay, uh for
paragraph
um
Let me find
the paragraph general policy for
paragraph. I want to upload that.
Um
So, for general policy, it's uploading
here as you would see the whole file is
just been paragraph by paragraph being
chunked. So, there is no heading, there
is no no separate information. And if
you look at the uh
if you look at that information as well,
if I can find it here quickly,
um
general
general paragraph uh policy paragraph as
you can see the information is just
paragraph by paragraph. So, you kind of
cleaned up your data again,
but you're dividing it based on the
different system. So, instead of heading
you're talking about paragraphs. That's
another way of uh
basically feeding your rag for your
information. Another way would be a
fixed 512 of character. You can say,
"Okay, one of the best practices for rag
is
you just divide based on 512 character,
and you have 64% overlap between the
chunks, so you won't lose the track."
So, if your data is just too
is not organized, if there's just random
data that you have and you can't clean
that up, that's another way
you can upload your document. So, that
would be instead of this,
you can choose another file, and
you can say basically there's another
paragraph
for global travel
uh
file here. So, that's kind of when it's
kind of overlap here when it's going to
see here that the about this chunking
strategy, you would see okay this
started for chunking and then
it ended in the 512,
and then
it's again
uh using that uh I think it was 64 uh
I was 64 overlap, yeah. So, it's using
the 64 overlap here again. So,
you would see it's basically
uh
chopped it from here.
And
so, from here to here is 512, and from
here to here is
32 then another 32 from here to
here. So, this is a 32 32 64 in total.
So, that's how it's relating each chunks
together. It's happening same for here.
As you can see it's happening same for
here. It's the way that
But you see the issue with that is it's
coming here to assist the next system.
So, it's breaking. It's not the best but
in some cases it works for you.
Another way that
we can do is
sentence base.
So, it can be based on first counting
based on the number of sentences and it
chop it there. There are different use
case for each ones. So, another
interesting one is imagine that you
There's some maintenance coming. You're
receiving some email and you just want
to quickly upload
the
document in your chat without
without cuz you do you don't have the
it's just a screenshot and you can't do
anything. Imagine you just receiving an
email and says, "Okay, there is a
maintenance plan for this day from this
hour and you just wants to upload this
in your chat
for the for the user. So,
if me as a employee ask, "Okay, what is
is there any maintenance plan for this
weekend?" Then I would know
immediately. So, another way that we can
easily upload that screenshot as well.
Let me find
easily upload that.
Oh, sorry. That wasn't our screenshots.
So, the screenshots
uh you can upload then we're using
another um
uh model that just turns that uh
image to text and text to .md and then
we're using this uh
uh basically uh what's the name? Uh the
sentence model for the emails that can
convert
uh
that image to a text and then it can
feed. So, we can see we're using the
chunking strategy a sentence group is
turned that image to text and it's
already
uh good for the
uh
for our chatbot. So, we can uh we can
index it into our knowledge base now.
So, then it's going to be a next one
that's been uploaded here screenshot. We
can see how it's been chunked because
this is just the email. It doesn't have
heading. It doesn't necessarily have all
the paragraph chunk properly. So, and if
it's a shortage of time it's a small
message temporary change. You don't need
to sit and clean up a data for here. You
just want to drag and drop updated for a
weekend and everybody knows okay uh this
weekend we're having a maintenance plan.
So, uh when they will come here and ask
is there any
maintenance plan for this weekend?
Then technically we should get the
result of
okay, this is the maintenance plan
that's been happening and the reference
documents. So, uh
the maintenance uh this is the exact
maintenance uh window that we got and
actually the reference you can see
that's the screenshot
that uh we uploaded just now. So, if we
do if we
had I done the screen
the file name better, there would have
been even a more relevant and somebody
says, "Okay, according to this
information that I got from here, we
have a maintenance plan
tomorrow from 6:00 p.m. onwards till
midnight." So, and I can easily archive
and delete any of these and then it
won't be visible as well. So, these are
basically different ways that you can
chunk. That's one of the
that's basically the one of the most
important part of the whole system
because most of the LLMs would just
work. The but the way you want to feed
that data and you want to clean that
data and
not
not having
just drag and drop the entire handbook
here and have a messy data,
that would help you a lot to have a more
successful in this case FAQ chatbot.
Uh
Yeah, so these different strategies
would help you as well.
And um
Yeah, let's
move on to the next slide.
Um
So, we're using we're using Postgres and
um
we are also having a few agents that
they are just Python codes. They are not
really any We're not calling another LLM
as an agent to do something for us. The
real one reason for that is the speed
cuz I'm running this locally. I'm having
running this on Ollama.
I don't have I don't need to three four
agents to loop three times four times
because then I'll have to wait I have to
wait 20 30 seconds for it and user would
lose the interest. You just want one
natural language to run.
The rest if something can be done by
a Python function, let's a Python
function then run it for you. Then you
have also the full control over the
function. Won't be any hallucination
because you need to you're going to
write your test suite so to just cover
most of the situations. So that would
help you. The agents uh
I just want to show you something here
in the settings
what can it be. So I can I can uh
off and have it agents off and on as
well. So I can say if somebody wants the
current date
then this function is it can be called
and retrieve. You don't need the LLM to
bring you back the current date. You
don't need the LLM to calculate for you
something cuz also another plan for
expanding this
expanding this chatbot is having it for
customer service for that's going to
talk about the products and the prices
and calculations. So that's another
thing product info or even having
another deeper search
on the agent mode. But the point with
that is then
cuz it's going to be another search then
you would lose that referencing on that.
That would be important. So
while I'm here, I'll show you what do I
have
as a LLM actually I'm using here. I'm
using the smallest Qwen 2.5.
So it's 0.5 billion is
parameters instruct model and it's
I think it's 400
megabytes only. So it's that small and
I'm using this model also for
for the agent mode if I want to run so I
would run and two more
I would run another one and I have to
run the agent mode is going to make it
slightly slower.
Um and then
Um yeah, let's go back to the slides
here.
Um
So
Yeah, this uh way of working you have a
full visibility on your poison function.
That's what's going on. So, you only
pass the in needed needed information
clear information to LLM and receive a
clear information. So, it would reduce
the chance of hallucination
dramatically.
Um also showing you here
about
uh vectors and things on the in the
database. So,
um
So, when we're going to chunk, we're
going to chunk the information. This is
based on the
ID and the section um
and the what kind of vector embedding
are we doing? And then um
we have our chunk, we have we can see
our basically
how it's going to find the nearest
neighbor here and um
Also, the keyword match at the same time
because if if you uh having a customer
service product chatbot, you don't have
no need the nearest information. You
need the exact information. If it comes
to the number as well, if it's come to
the product as well, you need exact uh
if it's a medical chatbot, you need the
exact medication. You need don't need
something similar or close to it. So, we
need to have both both basically
uh
keyword search and
um and the semantic search together. So,
we'll have a hybrid search that giving
you a better result.
And we're talking about the number
number
that we're going to have.
I have it in the system limited to two
because in this case you don't need more
than that.
But, if you want to retrieve some
information, if it's a product, you
might have you don't want to just uh
bring top two products that's being
there for the user because you might
have the same brand like a 20 product or
50 product of the same brand. If you
don't let the window your window to pull
those information, those products are
never going to be sold and never going
to be shown in the chatbot. So, it's
important how many you can fetch.
Uh
and then there the
more about the retrieval that when we're
using the BM25
to get the exact keywords. So, the
previous slide was about to get the most
closest with the cosine distance that we
have uh
because when we upload the
information with the in our vector in
our in our vector database,
the information with the similar
meanings are going to sit next to each
other.
And then when we user search for
something and ask for something, then uh
our information
and our
our search is going to convert
that uh question that query
uh in that database and go find a
similar closest information to that
question and will return it. So, that's
the reason we can't just one. We need to
return more than those so we have
multiple answers and more closer
answers.
But, here in the
smart retrieval, we need the exact
answer. So, we would need to we would
need to filter it based on the language,
for example, we need to based on the ID
or exact product name, SKUs, or
uh
brand name or something. So, that would
be the
the keyword uh
retrieval
uh for us.
And then how we do the ranking
based on
which is very important because when we
have the both vector and the BM25, we
want to mix these and still bring the
top
uh
top two or top five relevant answers
that we need
uh
for us. So, more accurate if we if we
bring too many if we bring top 20 here
and
uh
bring shows top 20 answers is going to
be quite confusing for the user. So, you
just want to have make sure you bringing
the right amount based on your
use case based based on your use case.
So, if you're having products, you would
bring more. You retrieve more.
If it's something medical, you retrieve
less.
Uh
you don't want
to information to be all over the place.
You want to accurate more accurate
information because you would have more
liability obviously on that.
Um
another point here is
um
So, this is
uh this is more about
reranker. So, when we have our reranker
here, uh
that would also um
bring the information bring that uh
And so, after that score
uh how many of those information that
shows by default. So, I'm only showing
two there.
Um so, I've I've briefly talked about
the agent mode vs. direct rag. The
direct rag is
is just uh following the
it's a fixed pipeline. It's not going to
go calling anything. You know, the the
path is
quite clear.
You have embed embedded query, you have
a hybrid retriever.
And you just bring up the answer.
It's good if compliance is quite
important for you.
But agent mode, you have a few extra
tools that going to be called. So, a
search is a compare product. These can
bring more information back. It's less
in your control.
So,
uh
Oh, that's quite important and it takes
longer because you have another agent
that going to work. So, basically it's
getting this information and then you
have agent mode based on your request is
going to call.
Um
So, that would that would take slightly
longer slightly longer.
Um
About that about the
telemetry and application guidelines.
So,
um
can use LangChain Fuse for we integrated
LangChain Fuse
uh in our functions. So, we can
uh see what kind of answers uh we have.
It's quite easy to everything is local.
It's no outside calling or anything. So,
it's easy to track the information that
was chatting with the widget anonymous.
I wasn't logged in. It's a FAQ FAQ chat.
That's FAQ agent is name of the
the whole projects that
I'm running there. So, each conversation
has a ID.
Uh
you can track
if there was any maintenance for this
weekend and you can track the answer for
it. You can see what model I've been
using. You can see that I've returned
the top two answers and the cuz it was
top two is referenced twice on that
image.
Um page at most was off.
Uh it was a chance.
Two chunk of information was returned
and it took this long milliseconds and
uh yeah.
That's basically the information we
have.
If you have external models, you can
even estimate the cost that you're
spending. That's another thing you can
uh
you can use that for.
And uh if you have different sessions,
different users, you can track the
logins. So, um
that's give you a good insight of how
users are treating you
uh
with your chat. So, um
Yeah. So, as I said about the user
sessions and IDs, um
and then you would have the guardrails
um as well. So, something because of you
using functions for it, we can
uh have a better control over it. So, if
I ask is chatbot, how do I
uh
treat flu?
I have created a section uh to say
without going to chatbot, the point of
lots of these guardrails is that the
issue should stop before we
um
the prompt injection or anything that we
have uh
or a question that is we're not supposed
to respond. We shouldn't even send it to
the
LLM to generate anything. So, before
even in the code, I can have So, we have
created a section here uh to say if
there is a medical escalation, bring
this medical message back.
Uh
and you can see how the system prompt is
quite small because I'm basically
prompting everything in the code, so
uh,
although the system prompt looks quite
small and just few sentences,
uh, I'm actually prompting way more in
the
uh, code.
Instead of prompt, we use I'm using the
code to say what do's and don'ts. And
uh, another example is the medical
escalation and you can add more based on
your
uh,
concerns you would have for your
product. So, um,
yeah. So, this is the example for that.
Um,
can be uh, can needs to be expanded with
different keywords, with different kind
of sentences. Should be cured and see
how many times somebody could pass this
or not. But technically, that would be
example of how we should block uh, I
have our guard there should block any
query that's not related.
Um, can do the same with the injection
and so on.
Um,
what else do we have here? We talked
about the length fuse and uh, we just
need to create a generate a key and you
have it in your
uh,
system. I would
I would work is just uh,
a little bit about the observability
that I've talked about.
Um,
and then um,
then the injection as well. So, the
tools for prompt injection again, it
shouldn't go to the LLM and be stopped
there. It should be stopped before
before uh,
it's being sent there.
And
yeah, we're using intent rejects and
term dictionaries and LLM classifier to
stop any of these issues. And of course,
we can expand it more. But the good
thing about that, because it's just a
code, it doesn't it It need the long
prompt. It doesn't need anything
uh
Uh outcome would be obvious. You know
what you uh blocking and what you're not
blocking. So, it's not like uh
uh LM that sometimes likes to listen to
you as you're
uh
as the instruction and sometimes just
escape and does its own thing. So, part
of that integrating all of these in your
Python before sending it is that you can
have rigid test and to say, "Okay, this
is what I'm blocking and this is why."
And it passes all the tests. So, you can
be more assured uh
about that.
Um
So, yeah. It's just a small slide about
uh
We can just create your the and I'm
having it as a um
I'm having it here as a as a
ba- uh as a widget. It could be also
done here um instead of um
in a bigger chat as well. So,
another thing is you have to in your
chat as a part of the rules, you should
say also if somebody doesn't understand
the terms that they're using. So, if
not, the person wouldn't allow me to
start the chat and not
and uh
Also, I gave the the widget capability
if I want. So, user, you can reset the
consent as well. It's just for my demo
purposes. So, and then the the widget
would show here.
Uh if I say no, this wouldn't work. If I
reset the consent, uh if I say yes, then
it will start.
Uh
So, yeah. So, that's also about the
widgets. And is cuz I'm using React, it
can be used anything else um um any
other
uh framework as well. I just use it for
simplicity.
Um here saying about Okay, the models I
used. So, I've used two models.
Uh
I pulled the quant 2.5.
Um
Actually, first I've had the 7 billion,
but it's um
took longer. So, for a smaller server,
I've changed it to uh
Let me show you the admin here.
uh 0.5. Otherwise, I have different
options. So, I was trying with different
models. If you have a bigger model, it's
just going to take longer. And it's
might be too wordy. Interesting finding
from my side was you don't need the
biggest model. You if you can vet your
data before sending it to your LLM, a
smaller smallest model can sort you out
and get a good uh
uh answer for you. And uh it would give
you less hallucination. It would uh
it's safer because it's not going to
make up information. If it doesn't have
information, it's simply it's going to
say no, I don't have that information.
So, that's another way of guard railing
um
to not uh to not have that issue of your
LLM randomly generating something.
Um
I have BGM
embedding models. So, when I upload
anything here that uh upload anything
here that embedding models basically
that embedding models do the embedding
for me.
Uh
so, technically you need two models
only.
Smallest chat model
and uh one one of the smallest
uh
uh one of the smallest model for
uh embedding.
And then, if you have it on Docker, one
click, everything's It's to be
running. You need your
uh
Python requirements to be installed and
then you have your React working on the
front end.
And then that's all you need. Uh
one more thing that I should be adding
here. I haven't the Langfuse also
uh should be added here. That's going to
be running in a different port. That's
missing from here.
So, the key takeaway for um
this is the structure markdown first.
So, we use Docling for uh
to do the heavy job. And then we use the
Postgres vector database to just store
everything. Uh
didn't use any specific framework. Uh
we just used
uh
Llama for our chats.
And no other uh paid framework anywhere
else. We used Lang Langfuse for our
telemetry. That was also free to use.
And this can be uh
escalated to different products as well.
It can be document catalog or from any
database.
Um
Thank you very much uh for your time. I
would like to get connected with you and
uh if you have any questions, if you
have
uh
any kind of concern or something that
you figure that would be uh better to
integrate, please share your idea with
me either in the comments or message me
on LinkedIn.
Um
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Uh thank you AI Engineer for the
opportunity.
And uh I'll see you next time. Cheers.